we just got done with the scoob movie
night
whoo watch along thanks to Warner
Brothers for sending over so much stuff
here's a photo yeah this is one there's
a second photo yeah - phone oh we got
more more look at us uh yeah yeah we're
Scooby dooby doo me fat yes please do
the whole review in this tone of voice
this is really truly what I want yeah
guys so we just watch this I gotta say I
really thought that they brought the
classic Scooby Doo to life as you can
tell by all the gear I'm wearing and how
grateful I am to Warner Brothers for
sitting over all those goodies I'm a
huge scooby-doo fan yeah
because a little disclaimer and it's not
really a big deal I've never seen any of
the movies or the live-action movies or
any of the animated show the original
but now I am ready for a franchise okay
I'm ready for so much more Scoob is John
wants to tell me what the plot is really
fast
oh boy well guess what Scoob and the
gang are on the hunt for some kind of
villain and it turns out that there's an
intergalactic plot that they need to go
on Shaggy and Scooby get abducted Scooby
is chosen for something mysterious and
the rest of the gangs got to go find
Shaggy and Scooby before all heck breaks
loose oh he said heck because this is
we're in a kids movie
okay so we got to make sure we're not
making a video that is made for kids on
you okay I got this covered don't you
worry Cleveland steamer boom don't need
to say any more than that now kids if
you look it up don't blame me that's on
you I'm not even telling you what the
definition of that but it's not kids
appropriate I'm gonna repeat it one more
time just for safety Cleveland steamers
know right Scooby uh yes so what I like
about this
well I'll tell you guys excited here I
do think this could be a movie I'm
probably yelling and this microphone
based off these sound waves I'm looking
at right here this could be a mood that
I think little kids would really like I
cannot obviously attest to the people
who were big fans of the Hannah Montana
hanna-barbera fanbase I'm sure there's
references that flew right over these
dog ears that I wore the entire time we
were watching the movie which I got a
pic intermittently there were jokes that
were definitely making me laugh true I'm
not gonna lie there I wouldn't say that
all the jokes made me laugh I'm true I
don't know what the scooby-doo fanbase
is like I don't I don't know if this is
like expecting entire scooby-doo fanbase
out there if you don't like our [ __ ] I
hate you as it is a human we're about to
find out I think there's some action
scenes in here that are shot really cool
I liked whenever there was like exciting
action stuff going on and there was some
good physical gags for sure the
voice-over work is is fine it's it's
it's amusing Mark Wahlberg was pretty
funny
in it what I found interesting is
someone who didn't even know the names
of the mystery Inc characters was I was
like there's a lack of mystery incan his
movie seems to be focused on building
some type of superhero universe or
cinematic universe scooby-doo and Shaggy
they've become friends with Fred and
your spot look at me I'm the biggest
scooby-doo you love it's not forget it
alright and then Daphne Daphne yes
scooby-doo and Shaggy are on this
complete other mission for majority of
the movie away from them it's almost
like they have the Shaggy and Scooby
move in they're like oh dang we forgot
the three other carries seemed like they
were really focused on this other team
that they're really building up for like
a spin-off movie or something are they
part of the Hannah
Barbera universe those other characters
at least blue falcon and dynomutt okay
alright that's a little bit more
forgiving I can't remember exactly if
for how much crossover exists with those
characters in the cartoons but yeah if
they're in the same you know animation
house yeah it was weird because I
thought Scooby Shaggy Blue Falcon and
whatever the hell that Avengers team is
called I can distinctly tell you about
them and all their personalities yes and
as someone who is my first time watching
a scooby-doo thing ever I can't really
tell you much about those other three
guys who I've seen their animation in
their design for my whole life but I
can't tell you anything about them
specifically what makes them entirely
unique other than they run mystery it
was a weird experience for me to be
watching and we weren't even like
talking during the movie we were
watching it we were really paying
attention I still found myself going I
could see how this could be little
disappointing for fans of the cartoon
growing up because it doesn't seem like
they really care much to flesh out the
mystery Inc stuff and it's more about
building up some bigger superhero like
movie but yeah John is someone who grew
up on scooby-doo even though you're not
the biggest scooby-doo fan now I am
alright I thought it was you know decent
you know I think you're absolutely
correct in that younger audience as I
think we'll have a really good time with
this and I think for kids who don't know
the old scooby-doo cartoons and stuff
like that there's plenty of potential
for enjoy about because now you got
people like me being indoctrinated I
don't know what that's gonna do because
yeah you're gonna have half the people
who didn't you know know the old stuff
being like so is this a superhero of
cinematic universe it seems really like
they took the Scooby Doo rights and went
what's popular now let's apply all that
to scooby - I really like the first 20
minutes genuinely where it was focused
more on the origins of how they met how
the friendship started forming and where
it's seamless I mean it was kind of
spooky he's got a scary scooby-doo
I don't I can't attest to that but I
imagine from what I've seen yeah this
movie has bookends that Park into the
original scooby-doo in fact there is a
recreated credit sequence that is
basically a 3d reimagining of the
original opening scene with all those
different classic monsters from
scooby-doo they water guy the robot tin
guy oh that's so cool yeah and so in the
beginning of the movie there's like an
endearing little sketch about how Shaggy
and Scooby meet and then there's like a
little bit of that familiar mystery Inc
stuff and then for the whole middle of
the movie for most of the movie you're
in this madcap adventure that to me
wasn't overly unique you know that it
has its moments and there are some jokes
that really land I really liked I really
liked Will Forte and Frank Welker
together you know as Shaggy and Scooby I
thought their report even when it wasn't
making me laugh so much I just enjoyed
spending time with them which is good
you know and especially for not the
classic voice I think Will Forte is a
terrific choice for him some of the
other voices do get a little lost and
yeah the mystery Inc team is basically
just they're archetypes and so that's
kind of what confused me too I feel like
they're really counting on us to know
Fred Daphne and Velma and the rest of
the stuff they're like let's let's
introduce you to it yeah yeah I feel
like I might have enjoyed the Fred
Daphne and Velma more if I if I actually
knew those characters and if their
mission the entire movie wasn't just to
get back to the a plot with Scooby yeah
but this movie is clearly designed as a
soft reboot of course you're looking at
younger newer audience I can't see
anyone really caring about those other
three yeah unless they just really like
their designs they only have the barest
of characterization and the rest is all
plot IV Fred's kind of funny
he loves his car that's a trade Velma
and Daphne were kind of nobody mmm is
smart that's a trait Daphne has an
alcoholic father that's a tree I mean
the other team got a lot of focus I got
this dog played by Ken Jong yeah yeah
yeah he he was a character and Mark
Wahlberg's character had like the
biggest heart of them all
feels like it's about everyone goes
through the most change and Scooby was
funny
I don't know everything was kind of like
two-dimensional yeah and I mean the
animated movie it's kind of weird to say
but it was very it felt two-dimensional
yeah and I mean there's a lot of pretty
familiar slapstick and a lot of pop
music and you know popular dance moves
and stuff totally stop underselling
classic character gotta get sued Warner
burger Sena stuff we this is pleasant
enough I just as nostalgic for the
original Scooby Doo am not really sated
in that corner - those bookends at the
beginning in the end which did and dear
me a little bit but movie it's fine and
I'm sure some kids will enjoy
I think Scooby and Shaggy were really
fun with those two characters I imagine
they're the most important to get down
Scooby Shaggy and Mark Wahlberg
spiritually I think is tricky because
you know the whole point of the original
is that these aren't supernatural
they're very real and they only appear
supernatural at first and I thought they
could have done something with that as a
movie but they do make the choice and I
feel like this is where some hardcore
Scooby nuts are gonna have their line
drawn they really go full-on fantasy
this is a completely fantasy action
movie adventure even the scary stuff is
is only wallpaper alright guys well
Scoob did you watch it are you gonna
watch it my god love it I got so much so
much so much crap here now you got so
many plushies to play with hats to
mailer I was like sure man I could go
for a shirt all the toys every kitchen
I'm glad they're taking care of my
family and my extended family who's
staying with me so now I got something
for everyone who's staying here now
anybody who comes in now just gets a
Scoob
party favor subscribe take what you want
about our feelings you know what do you
think our bottom line is huh check it
out hey you know John we should do a
patron in the day
oh that's a good idea Victoria Huntley
hey hello scooby-doo big in um in
Britain yeah it's say yes for the sake
of this shout out now Victoria I know
you like to do some cosplaying alright
and I'm just gonna say like if you like
to cosplay as Hermione from time to time
after watching this movie I couldn't
help but think Victoria should be
cosplaying as like Velma jinkies or
Daphne catchphrase you look great your
fiance would appreciate that or or check
this out
you could cosplay as shaggy and your
fiance could cosplay as Scooby and then
BAM fanfiction come to life you and your
fiance Shaggy and scooby-doo each agging
and doing yeah exactly
some kind of Austin Powers II scooby-doo
crossover would work they're both
children of the 60 and because you're
British and you cosplay and you have
fiance you might have kids this would be
a great conceiving story rest your child
is scrappy-doo
everyone's gonna lie hope you
appreciated this